[Music]
hello and welcome to Marshall matters
with me Winston Marshall at The
Spectator today I'm joined by Seth
Dillon the owner and CEO of Babylon B
who are currently enjoying a lockout
from Twitter over a joke and Babylon B
are American political satire website
and uh group so self welcome thank you
so much for taking the time to speak
with me what's going on what what can
you tell me about this uh this lockout
yeah I mean it's a weird situation here
where we uh we're being required to
delete a joke in order to stay on the
platform or at least be able to continue
to tweet on the platform our account is
still live it's you can go visit it on
Twitter but you we just can't tweet
anymore until we delete this tweet that
they want us to get rid of
um and what happened I mean the back
story is just there was this report that
came out in the USA Today uh that named
Rachel Levine as one of their picks for
women of the year
um and Rachel Levine is this transgender
official in the health department
um and uh and we did a joke a take on
that where we we named Rachel Levine as
our pick from Man of the Year kind of
disputing this idea that Rachel Levine
is actually a woman and it was a parody
a satirical take on that and uh it ran
afoul of their hateful conduct policy so
they can they consider this a case of
misgendering it's hateful conduct not
allowed on their platform in my view
it's like well if you don't like this
joke uh fine you can delete it yourself
but don't force me to delete it and
acknowledge that I engaged in hateful
conduct when I don't think that I did
you know in my opinion it's misgendering
somebody when you call uh someone who's
biologically male a woman I think that's
misgendering but they think it's
misgendering the other way around so you
know having those disagreements fine
Twitter can have their policies but
don't make us delete the tweet and admit
that we engage in hateful conduct we've
refused to do that and that leaves us in
this kind of stalemate situation where
we're locked out of our account we can't
tweet
um and they seem to be perfectly happy
with that yeah it seems like this see of
all you know all the thousands and
hundreds of thousands of jokes perhaps
that are made on Twitter every day
you've hit one this transgender issue
this is the highest ranking U.S official
ever in the history of America who is a
transgender and so you you seem to have
hit the sensitive Sweet Spot
um for people of I suppose a different
ideological ideology to yourself or
um uh
well it seems from the outside that
America is very split at the moment and
and for one side this is The Sweet Spot
is that anything that's fair right
well it's one it's certainly one of the
hot button issues right now you know
there's and and I don't know how this is
playing out around the world but here
you know we have in in sports college
sports professional sports you start
having these transgender athletes who
are male athletes they're male athletes
their sex is male but they're competing
in women's sports and they're dominating
women's sports uh Leah Thomas is an
example of this Leah Thomas is
transgender winning all these races
setting World Records uh weight lifters
you know that you got all this stuff
happening where
um it's a it's a conversation right now
that's being had and and there's a lot
of people who are pushing back against
it and saying look this isn't fair this
isn't right but you know we're also
getting into this conversation of
language and pronoun usage and whether
you're misgendering or dead naming and
there's a lot of strict enforcement
that's being done trying to compel your
speech so that you say what you're
supposed to say and if you don't say it
or you refuse to say it or you say the
wrong thing you know you get punished
for it so instead of having a debate 8
we have this situation where these
companies that have all this power you
know they have all this uh control over
who's allowed on their platforms and
who's allowed to speak they're trying to
settle the debate by just simply
silencing one side of the debate and
making them shut up
um and that's you know that's kind of an
unhealthy spot to be in as a society
well Babylon B you've you've had various
accusations I guess before and obviously
you're a comedy Saturday but you've been
accused of spreading misinformation uh
and and and the starch again uh to if
you were to judge all comedy all of its
misinformation because it's a joke it's
not technically true but this is a
little bit different because some people
might argue actually you're saying
something that is technically true so
they can't get you with a fact check
here because you're saying she is a
biological man
um and so uh instead of uh the sort of
misinformation fact checking you you're
locked out and this seems different
because it's not a shadow ban it's not a
a sense answering well I guess it's a
type of censoring but by by for example
in over here there's a bridge an Irish
comedian actually called Graham Linehan
uh who's the man behind Father Ted and
various
huge comedy shows over here and he got
banned from Twitter for the Tweet men
aren't women though and so it's the same
category it's the same hot button issue
but so uh why why is it that
um for Babylon B it's it's this new
approach what's going on at Twitter that
that they need to take you down in this
way like why why is it so important to
them well I do think it's a new approach
I think you know you mentioned the
misinformation same thing so we've dealt
with that quite a bit where our jokes
all of a sudden our jokes had a had a
Truth rating right where they were
either true or false and of course these
are fabricated stories satire the way
the political satire works is you like
you exaggerate the truth you make up a
story
um that is hyperbolic and it just it
goes It goes a Step Beyond the truth and
the direction the truth is pointing
usually you know like you're trying to
um do a parody and uh and so you know
the details of the story are always
going to be false
um but the underlying point that you're
making is oftentimes true and I think
that's the case in this story you know
it's you're advancing a truth we we
describe what we're doing is we're
speaking truth to culture we're just
doing it using humor and irony and
exaggeration so you can definitely fact
check the details of a story that's
fabricated like ours and say this is
false yes but that's missing the point
of course it's false it's a joke you
don't stand up in a comment show in fact
check the comedians say hey that's not
funny it's false you know it's it's a
joke but there is underlying truth to it
and that's where it gets kind of
confusing it's like now wait a minute
um you know we object to being
fact-checked and and we object to people
calling our stuff misinformation but now
we're standing by this one joke saying
this is the truth well of course you
know the the point of this joke did we
really name Rachel Levine Man of the
Year no The Babylon B doesn't name
anybody Man of the Year that's not
something that we do we're a satire site
it's a joke but Rachel Levine is in fact
a man in our view uh and I think that's
an objective uh an objective statement
that can be fact checked uh
affirmatively so there is truth to the
joke um there is often truth to to
satirical jokes and I think that's just
the problem when we talk about the
Babylon B and why we are facing you know
these kinds of things is because there
are popular narratives popular uh uh
views ideology narratives that are being
Advanced from the top down uh from our
government from our politicians from
media and entertainment and our
education system coming from the top
down these Progressive ideas this
narrative that they want to uh force on
everybody and get everybody to comply
with and affirm and we poke holes in
that you know we consider that punching
up we consider that speaking truth to
power we consider it speaking truth to
Culture by trying to poke holes in that
popular narrative other comedians are
out there trying to promote the popular
narrative and they're and they're going
for like applause and affirmation rather
than Amusement they're not trying to
make people laugh they're trying to make
people agree with them and agree that
this narrative is the one true narrative
that we should all be you know hailing
and cheering on
um and I don't think that's the job of
the comedian the job of the comedian is
to push back on that stuff and I think
that's why we're under attack is because
we're doing that effectively do you do
you think those other comedians you're
referring to and I'd be curious to know
who you specifically mean are are they
actually affirming it or is America so
split now that there are two
Completely Different World Views and for
comedy to work you need to have agreed
upon underlying truth underlying world
view to make fun of are these other
comedians you're referring to are they
actually affirming that stuff or do they
just have such a different Outlook that
they genuinely find something that you
don't find funny they find it funny well
there's definitely an issue where you
have you know you have two different
views of the world uh well not just two
but let's keep it simple you know you've
got the left and the right right there's
a lot of people in between so I don't
want to oversimplify but just for the
sake of argument
um you know you've got people on the
left you've got people on the right they
see the world very differently
um up is down for one side black is
white for the other they disagree on a
lot of things and that does play into
comedy you know you really shouldn't
have you really shouldn't have like
right-wing Comedians and left-wing
comedians comedians should be making fun
of whatever it deserves to be made fun
of and in our view you know and this is
why we often make fun of our own side
you know I think it's I think it's
important that we like hold our our own
side to account and uh criticize
ourselves when we're engaged in
hypocrisy or when we're advancing bad
ideas harmful ideas
um things that don't make sense things
that are incoherent or hypocritical
they're deserving of mockery and
ridiculous comedians should be making
fun of their own side when that's when
that's necessary I do think there's some
people on the left who do that I think
Bill Maher is a good example of that
Bill Maher is often holding his own side
to account for
um you know cancel culture uh wokeness
um you know this this that these attacks
on Comedy and Free Speech you know he
pushes on that back on that pretty hard
even though
um you know he agrees with the left on a
lot of the on a lot of their core issues
and I certainly don't see eye to eye
with him on most things
um but I you know you have this
situation where there are both sides
trying to speak their truth and Advance
their truth I think when when I'm
talking specifically about promoting the
popular narrative you know when I think
of our late night TV shows you know like
late shows evening shows Saturday Night
Live stuff like that the jokes that
these guys are making
um they're not really attached to
reality they're attached to a narrative
they're riding on the back of a false
narrative and they're promoting that
narrative very aggressively and you
often hear in their like their stand-up
routines that they're like they're
basically preaching they're preaching to
the choir that the audience loves it
they're standing up and they're clapping
and they're applauding there's not a lot
of laughing happening it's like they're
not even making jokes anymore it's a
really strange time to be in when you
have comedians who are so dedicated to
advancing The Narrative that it becomes
less about making people laugh and more
about getting their Applause
um and so I've been seeing that a lot
and I think that comedians who push back
on this kind of stuff Dave Chappelle
would be a good good example
some of Joe Rogan's comments
um you know like people who are who are
getting canceled over here are
challenging the popular narrative making
jokes they're not supposed to be making
I think that's the job of the comedian
it's the job that we're trying to do and
I think it's the reason that we're
facing some attacks
uh I mean could your detractors not say
that you were playing to your own crowd
and what's the philosophy at Babylon Bay
is the priority the joke do you do you
guys um you've been described and I
don't I'd rather you described your own
uh team and and the Babylon be yourself
but you're described as Christian
conservative satire group do you have
your own agenda or is the agenda just to
make people laugh because that should be
the agenda or do you have a political
motive yourselves
well so a couple a couple parts there I
mean the first thing that it that a
humorist or or comedian should be
thinking of when they're writing a joke
is is it funny that's the first thing is
it funny
um and kind of like a second question to
that is you know in evaluating whether
or not it's funny is to ask well is it
true because if it's not true it's not
going to be funny you know there's this
idea we we're criticized so heavily
sometimes that some of our jokes are
believable or that our jokes end up
coming true and I don't think that's a
really a very good criticism because you
know the saying that there's a grain of
Truth in every joke or it's funny
because it's true there's a reason that
those are are common sayings they're
common idioms you know these are these
are uh phrases that reflect the reality
that a joke needs to be closely Tethered
to the truth in order to go through it
in order to make a point there has to be
an underlying truth to the point that
you're making so if you divorce your
jokes so far from reality that nobody
could possibly believe it was true then
nobody's gonna laugh at it nobody's
gonna think that it's funny
so um I think you have to ask yourself
is it funny but then second to that well
is it true it's it's only going to be
funny if it's true so okay if we're if
we're telling a joke that's rooted in a
truth and not just a narrative that we
want to advance that's a joke worth
telling
um and that's really how how we come at
it in terms of
um you know trying to entertain people
we do want to make people think though
you know there's there's it's kind of a
two-pronged approach where you want to
make people laugh but you also want to
make them think I think that the
satirist has an important role to play
in society in terms of
um ridiculing bad ideas ridiculing
dangerous ideas before they take root
and before they become policy and start
affecting people and and uh and harming
people in society you know that that
that mission
um it's not really a political mission
in the sense that it's uh oh you know
all all Democrat ideas are bad and need
to be ridiculed Republican ideas are
good let's Advance Republican ideas and
tear down Democrat ideas uh it's not
like that it's more like
um you know what it which ideas are
harmful which ideas are hypocritical and
that can be on both sides and so that's
where we end up we do end up going after
both sides
um obviously because we're we ourselves
are uh primarily on our staff our
conservatives and Christians we have our
own world view
um but we're not trying to shove that
world view down your throat we're just
simply writing comedy from our own world
view and trying to to the best of our
ability say is this true and funny
so you're now you're in this standoff
with Twitter how does it end you're not
going to back down it sounds like what's
going on behind the scenes are you in
conversation with them
we're not uh we did submit an appeal so
when they told us that we had to delete
this tweet and it and it says in the in
the red language above the delete button
it says by deleting this tweet you
acknowledge that you engaged in hateful
conduct
um that's the reason that we're kind of
taking a stand and saying you know we
can't in good conscience click that and
and acknowledge that because we don't
agree that we engaged in hateful conduct
for one thing I don't think it's hateful
to tell the truth you know I don't think
that I don't think that's truth telling
is hate speech it can't be hate speech
um you know and and so this idea that
that the problem is you know they've
baked their ideology into their terms of
service so that if you disagree with
their ideology you're automatically
engaging in hateful conduct well we just
simply disagree that that constitutes
hateful conduct and we think that their
ideology uh they're trying to get us to
conform even as they say in their terms
of service that they want a platform for
free expression that has a diverse range
of perspectives uh represented there
that what they give with one hand they
take back with the other and having all
these rules about what you can and can't
say and you've got to agree and conform
with their ideology in order to stay
there so they don't really want a
platform for free expression
um I think I lost track of the question
though what was oh the question was have
we have we talked with him and what's
going on and where does it go from here
um we haven't had a conversation with
them we did appeal it and they denied
our appeal and so what that means is
something else is going to have to give
I mean if we're not going to delete the
Tweet we will never tweet again unless
something changes if there's a policy
change at Twitter if Elon Musk takes
control and decides to free the bee
um you know maybe Congress will pass
some law that will that will change
things it could be a while before we get
out of Twitter jail
how deep rooted are these problems is it
the ideology of those who work at
Twitter or are there legal issues uh is
is there a more deep-rooted legal uh
fight that you have to take on in in the
states
great question I think it's two things I
mean yeah there's obviously
there's obviously a um a strong
um position that this company takes and
that most of its staff take on these
issues you know people on the left here
in in the states in particular
um they don't they do not want free
speech platforms they really don't
whatever lip service they may give to
that they don't they want to crack down
on coveted misinformation they want to
crack down on just misinformation in
general anything that might impact an
election that could harm them is
misinformation the hunter Biden laptop
story is misinformation get rid of it we
don't like it misinformation just means
you know stories that we don't like that
we don't want you to read
um and then they also do this with hate
speech you know any any opinion that
they don't like is automatically labeled
hate speech and taken down they really
have no interest in a free speech
platform and they try to say that they
have interest in it there's just certain
things that they don't want up there
like misinformation and hate speech but
really those are just opinions that they
don't like so there's that problem which
is very deep rooted it goes all the way
down to the you know the majority of the
employees that are on staff there have
these views and there's tons of pressure
from the outside as well that they keep
these platforms clean of misinformation
and hate speech which is just simply
Republican or conservative viewpoints
you had this happen so Trump got elected
in 2016 here and then by 2018 you know
Facebook for example was taking a
tremendous amount of blame for that
because they allowed so much
misinformation to proliferate on their
platform that's why Trump got elected so
they were pressured from the outside to
crack down on misinformation and start
fact checking everything that's when our
jokes started getting fact checked was
in 2018 when when Facebook is deciding
they need to crack down and prevent
another situation like this the only
reason Trump could have won is because
Facebook let too much misinformation
spread right you had you had
conservatives who were allowed to talk
without being filtered and without being
censored and so you know that's really a
super deep rooted problem where it's not
just within the company itself but
there's outside pressure and then you
have compounding that the legal issues
here where our laws haven't yet caught
up to the conditions of the of our
society right now where we have the Town
Square the Public Square is no longer a
physical Town Square in the middle of
the town
it's these privately owned digital
platforms these forums where people
communicate online it's where the vast
majority of public discourse is taking
place not just between private citizens
but between government officials and
private citizens
unprecedented amounts of speech are
happening there this is where public
discourse happens tens of millions of
active daily active users are on these
platforms communicating with each other
so the laws haven't caught up to that
yet to protect speech
um what you know we still have these
outdated laws that are basically giving
these companies complete immunity to do
whatever they want uh and and I don't
think that that's a great situation and
there needs to be a solution for that so
that can either come through Congress or
the courts but so you do have a legal a
legal conversation to have there as well
well I I think what you're referring to
is something is it's a the communication
Act was actually 1996 so 10 years before
uh sorry 20 years before uh Trump's uh
election win and
um uh and and there's a sort of paradox
or a contradiction within uh section 230
which is on the one hand uh these uh
internet uh platforms are immune from
the UH responsibilities of a normal
publisher on the other hand they have uh
I think it says two section 230c Parts
one and parts two and parts two is the
Samaritan uh the Good Samaritan act or a
Good Samaritan something or other which
says that uh they have the they're
obliged to monitor uh output and and
content regardless of whether
um the constitutional rights of the
users are infringed upon so that seems
to me that you can't have both of those
you it's one or the other either they
are responsible as Publishers or they're
not responsible and they should allow
all speech regardless of of whether they
believe it to be hate speech or not is
that the is that the legal root of the
problem or or is that the problem is it
worse or is not as bad as that
well I mean they do they are in a
situation where they're they're where
they're essentially getting to have
their cake and eat it too right because
they get the immunity
um uh from liability uh as a legal
benefit so they can basically moderate
whatever they want to and take down
whatever they want to and they're immune
they're not treated as a publisher for
doing that it's not considered
um you know the in the language in
section 230 deals with like interactive
Computer Services which are just like
online forums and then like content
providers and they're not considered
like a a content provider when they
engage in that activity so they get that
immunity which is which is which was a
good thing because it allowed the
internet to really flourish it allowed
these forums these public Publishers uh
or these uh internet
um uh social networks and everything to
get off the ground and actually grow and
not be you know uh saddle down with all
of this uh legal trouble you know with
people suing them for the moderation
they're engaging in everything it was a
good thing to an extent the issue is
it's like okay well they can have their
cake and eat it too because
they're allowed to get this immunity for
engaging in in all kinds of censorship
um and and it but it crosses the line
into kind of this publisher activity
where rather than just being like the
newsstand that hosts all of the
different you know Publications they're
actually choosing which Publications go
up uh and and what you can see and what
you can hear
um and so they're getting that they're
getting that uh and and I think that
part of the problem is that this
immunity isn't conditioned on anything
like political neutrality or anything
like that you know if you if you simply
conditioned the immunity so that when
especially with large public forums when
these forums get to a certain size and
they have so much reach and they are
basically the de facto Town Square as
Elon Musk called it uh you know that's a
special situation that you have there in
that situation I think the immunity that
they enjoy let them enjoy it but
condition it on politically uh political
neutrality so that they're not engaging
in politically motivated Viewpoint
discrimination you really harm Society
you harm culture you harm democracy when
you allow platforms that are that large
that have that much control of the flow
of information and the public discourse
to engage in politically motivated
Viewpoint discrimination so the problem
is the the law has we didn't foresee
this happening no one could foresee this
happening it wasn't in view back in 1996
when this was passed and so I think it
needs an update it doesn't need to be
abolished I think it needs to be either
reformed or we need to apply some other
kind of Doctrine to these platforms and
this is you know getting a little
technical I guess but you had justice
Thomas here our Supreme Court Justice
Clarence Thomas
um
recently give some remarks on this whole
issue and say that the immunity
provisions of section 230 have been
interpreted very extravagantly by the
lower courts maybe it's time for the
Supreme Court to take a look at it and
determine whether or not that
interpretation is correct maybe it needs
to be interpreted less extravagantly
maybe common carrier Doctrine which is
applied to you know telecommunications
companies needs to be applied to these
companies that are carrying as conduits
so much of this communication they
shouldn't be allowed to discriminate not
on the basis of race Creed sex or
political Viewpoint and so you know
that's not a huge regulatory scheme that
would involve you know the government
just taking over these platforms and
running them there's plenty of precedent
for common carrier Doctrine being
applied to large telecommunications
companies and it not being a First
Amendment issue where the rights of
those companies are being you know their
first amendment rights are being
Abridged these these private companies
will say we don't want to be the speaker
of your speech we don't want to host
your speech that we have a first
Amendment right to not carry your
messages if we don't want to but which
is it are they the speaker or not if
they're just the conduit and they're not
going to be treated as the speaker
um you know then they should be required
to host other people's speech whether
they want to or not it's just the nature
of the platform that they've built so
that's where they're having their cake
and eating it too and I think there are
potential solutions to it I just I'm not
a legal scholar I'm not a First
Amendment scholar I'm just dealing with
the you know the cancer culture and uh
and uh and censorship side of it from a
business perspective and surveying the
options out there and what's being
discussed I think there are possible
Alternatives well you mentioned Elon
Musk there and at the time of speaking
now uh it was been a week since he
bought largest stakeholder he's now the
largest stakeholder shareholder rather
in Twitter and there's been free the bee
uh trending online uh as a consequence
what do you what do you make of the musk
deal uh his his take over and what do
you um uh what do you think its
implications are for social media and
Twitter specifically going forward well
it's a wild situation I did not expect
Elon Musk to get involved in this whole
thing you know but I think I think from
his perspective and you know some of the
comments that he's made about about this
whole situation talking about Twitter
being the de facto Town Square polling
his audience to see if if they think
that Twitter adheres to his principles
of free expression which are really
necessary he calls himself a free speech
absolutist and so you know from his his
perspective when he sees all this
censorship including censorship of the
president of the United States media
companies like the New York Post trying
to report on the hunter Biden laptop
story satire sites like ours you know
getting locked out of our account
because we made a joke that the powers
that bee didn't like he sees that kind
of stuff happening and thinks well you
know if Congress isn't going to do
anything or if if Twitter is not gonna
uh respect free expression then maybe
there's another approach I mean there's
there's been a common thing where you
have these like activist investors who
will buy up a lot of stock in a company
and get on the board or start to
exercise some control using their
influences large shareholders to get to
cut to steer the company in the
directions they want it to go and he
seems to have decided that it's time to
do that at Twitter and he's one of the
few people in the world who has the
resources to actually make it happen I
mean the stake that he bought is still
it's a minority stake he doesn't have
control of the company yet and it cost
him billions of dollars so it's uh
clearly he's putting his money where his
mouth is though by getting involved and
I welcome it I think that you know
people with his mindset this that really
values free expression free speech
I think people like him need to get
aggressive and need to be willing to
invest in the preservation of freedom
and the restoration of Sanity uh if
people who have the resources to do it
actually do it they might actually make
a difference a lot faster because so
many of us you know little guys like us
we get locked out and all we can do is
Scream into the void there's nothing we
can do about it we don't have the money
to buy Twitter and take it over
um musk does it's you know you mentioned
the hunter Biden uh laptop case and the
New York Post uh story being being
censored during the election and and and
and I see this now with Babylon B at
some point I I wonder to a lot of people
in denial that these things are
happening or don't even know these
things are happening I certainly have a
lot of friends just who they don't they
live in a completely different world and
they don't see this stuff going on and I
do wonder what it's going to take for
them to think oh actually maybe we've
got a problem but perhaps I that's
that's even here in in England I don't
know if you have a sense of that in in
the states of of this this great
division
um that's that's happened over the last
five ten years maybe longer I I I don't
know if you have insight into the into
that on your side of of the uh the world
that are reasonable people who are
viewed as a problem there's so many
people though here on the left who don't
think it's a problem at all I mean they
think it's a problem that that the
people who disagree with them are
allowed to speak you know it's not that
they have a problem with hate speech
they just hate speech they hate speech
they hate free speech and so that is a
big problem and getting people to wake
up to that I think there are a lot of
there are a lot of middle of the road
kind of reasonable people who might be
more inclined to vote for a Democrat
than a republican because of social
issues or whatever you know they're
totally for same-sex marriage you know
they're they they they're not really
like super religious or conservative or
anything but but when it comes to like
clamping down on and and uh on stories
that you don't like and muzzling voices
that you don't want to hear a lot of
these people still love Liberty you know
one of the founding principles of our
country was Liberty that was at that was
the heart at the heart of everything
liberty liberty liberty and uh and we
have this situation now where so many
people are just completely
um either forgetting that or or thinking
that you know we don't need it anymore
that it's harmful or detrimental to
society to have too much Liberty and so
I'm hopeful I mean I I try not to be a
cynical person uh I try to try to see
the positives I'm hopeful that you know
when when things get too extreme in One
Direction they do tend to swing like a
pendulum back in the other direction a
little bit people start to see oh maybe
we went too far this way let's come back
to kind of the reasonable middle uh I'm
hopeful that there will be a swing back
towards the Middle where people see that
this is going a little bit too far
where's that hope coming from is it from
someone like musk and his baby or are
you is their hope because because you
see people on the other side actually
thinking perhaps this is going too far
a little bit of both I mean I mentioned
Bill Maher earlier you know he sees the
problems with this stuff the guys are
you know the guy's a leftist he's not
he's not even in the middle he's on the
left solidly
um but he but he but he does believe in
free speech he thinks that people on the
right should still be able to talk
um I think that more people like him
need to be very vocal uh they will
embolden others to to stand up and say
you know this isn't right this isn't
this isn't good we need to have these
dialogues we need to have these
discussions
um I think that it's it's a shame there
aren't more people in positions of real
power and influence like musk who are
doing stuff like this but look musk May
embolden other people to step up there's
a lot of you know there's a lot of
influential people that could be doing
more I think the little stand that we're
taking I'm not going to take credit for
much but we are refusing to bend a knee
we're refusing to say we're going to
delete this tweet we're willing to give
up our Twitter presence which is uh
significantly impactful on our business
on principle and say you shouldn't be
silencing jokes that you don't like
especially when they're rooted in the
truth
so you know hopefully we will encourage
other I remain hopeful that that people
will kind of stand up and band together
and eventually push back on this stuff
and maybe we play a small part in that I
don't know I could be wrong maybe we
just die out with the rest of them well
I'm hopeful to accept them let's let's
leave on on a note of Hope there thank
you so much for your time and
um uh we really appreciate it and we
will be watching attentively to see what
happens next in this great standoff
thank you thank you for having me on I
appreciate a great dialogue
foreign
[Music]